a work session of the special House
special election committee uh special
committee on Child Care we'll do the
Paige
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for us okay awesome
um all right so uh good news is today
should be relatively short
um we're gonna start
um one thing I think will go pretty
quickly
um the background check process the
other thing that we need to start taking
some time on is the licensing process
and the reason that's gonna that we will
probably not finish all that today
because the reason is is that licensing
process
um touches a lot of things
um so um the reason I was the last one
getting here uh is I was going through
and accumulating all of the licenses and
all of the rsas so I'm the people at
print services are a huge fan of me
um because this is this is double page
double-sided every RSA that you would in
theory have to know to open a licensed
Child Care Center in the state of New
Hampshire
um so you know it's um as you know
um
with the laws you know one thing touches
one thing and touches another thing it
touches another thing um so this is
everything that originates from RFA 170
uh which is the governing
um uh governing I'm like leaning forward
here the governing
um RSA over uh licensed Child Care
Centers
um so obviously it deals heavily with
things like child safety uh parental
rights
um but in theory you would have to know
all 288 pages of this uh and then the
101 pages of additional regulations uh
from Department of Health consumer
services under h-e-c h4002
um which of which we added nine pages of
regulations of summary regulations last
year which amounted to about 37 pages of
actual regulation so in total
um 288 plus 101
um so you know quick math 389 389 pages
in theory that we would expect someone
opening a licensed Child Care Center to
read understand and follow
um so I get a feeling
um that when we start digging through
that licensing process
um we will hopefully find some ways to
not cut corners but maybe
um abbreviate the process
um so uh we're going to start off with
the background check process so the
reason the background so the background
check process
um this is in order to work in a
licensed Child Care Center you obviously
need to pass a state background check so
there's been two
um there's there's two major problems
that we have so obviously this is we
have a Workforce problem right of people
getting into Child Care Centers right
you can't hire people right here it's
that for a lot of Industries but it's
really bad for child care centers
because you have to pass a background
check to work there so in order to pass
background check right now and we have
I've distributed to the members
um the background check process uh from
the state about what to do
um but basically you have to schedule a
fingerprint appointment
um which can take anywhere from two to
three weeks just to get it scheduled
um then you have to go to there we have
a problem in the state I believe there's
only five
centers in the state that do the
electronic fingerprinting
um so you have to go there and then you
have to once that is done then you
submit your application off uh in paper
um with a 28 check to the Department of
Health and Human Services uh where they
will then approve or deny you
um and there was a shortcut that I
believe ended on December 7th
um where we were granted a waiver it's a
federal requirement we were granted a
waiver
um that allowed us basically once the
applicant was fingerprinted they could
have a waiver
um that allowed them to work in the
child care center provided they were not
left alone with children
um I'm exploring that waiver my
understanding is it's no longer in play
and that if the state would have to pay
a 700 000 fine to basically start doing
that again so one of the things that I
will ask the committee is should we
consider paying that fine and getting
that process going again
um I'm not the chairman yes who are we
paying the fine to that would be the
federal government
of them yes not yes people have mixed I
hear mixed reviews
um by the way anybody feel free to chime
in on this um I'm just kind of brain
dumping my this process
um so there's a couple of things that my
understanding is is that we actually
make the process longer needlessly
um I was told that I need to confirm and
I'm trying to kind of poke around that
the electronic fingerprints are not
actually necessary
um the fingerprinting is necessary the
electronic fingerprinting is not
necessary and I do know from personal
experience one of my jobs that I helped
two years ago working for a federal
contractor was I did the fingerprint
downward in HR I did the fingerprinting
there's no license in the state of New
Hampshire to do fingerprints fun fact
one of the few things we don't license I
have the same look when I figured that
out it's the same look there's no
license it's a Boy Scout merit badge
though yeah it's a voice it turns out we
don't require you to have a license to
do this
um so
um you know anyone can anyone can
literally go on Amazon and buy the FBI
fingerprint cards and an ink pad it's
thirty four dollars and we used to take
them so I asked uh someone who shall
remain nameless at DHHS why don't we
take that anymore and they said it's
inconvenient
um so uh
you know obviously there are problems
with the issues that there's only five
of these stations in the state
um by the way that distribution is not
Equitable
um if you live basically in Sullivan
County or the North Country you are
driving at least an hour hour and a half
to get to a fingerprint station which
you can only schedule two to three weeks
out I hope it doesn't snow hope you
don't miss it because if you don't make
it good luck
um and then the other thing that I have
discovered in my
um
exploration of the background check
process so you go and get your
fingerprinting and then you go to the
New Hampshire connections portal and
they mentioned that here in the they
mentioned that here in the this letter
from the chief of the license the
licensing Care Unit
um I believe that basically you go to
the New Hampshire connections portal and
you fill out all this information and
you have your connections forward and
you click submit
and then nothing happens
um because they will not take your stuff
unless it has a wet signature so that's
when you have to print it all out in a
digital age we have to print it all out
just like I just made a lot of friends
upstairs and Print Services
um you have to print it all out put it
into an envelope put a stamp on that
envelope address it send it off with a
check for 28 so something that I would
think we could consider looking at is
there's no reason they have to take a
wet signature if somebody has provided
their driver's license number their
social security number you have their
fingerprints
why do they have to sign a piece of
paper
um so what I would like to us to see is
exploring as a part of Expediting this
process that doesn't involve paying the
700 fine would be dictating to the
Department of Health and services that
they may take an electronic signature
and they may fully automate that process
um I would also like to explore why we
charge 28 bucks I have a moral issue
with charging people to get a license to
work if the state's going to require the
state should foot the bill that's my
opinion that may not be universally Fair
shared
um however uh there's also no reason we
couldn't take an online payment with a
credit card online Secretary of State
takes money online there's no reason
somebody has to cut a check and then
mail it off that's Arcane so these are
things that in my experience and
exploration of the background check
process I found that we could
expedite the process because what
happens is you hire these people
right so let's say you have somebody
who's never worked in child care or
something we'll talk about in a minute
never worked in um
New Hampshire child care
is is that you are competing with every
other employer in a state that has a 2.1
unemployment rate and so if you tell
somebody hey I'm going to hire you and
in three weeks we're going to go get you
fingerprinted and then after that we're
going to send some mail off and then
maybe I'll see you in a month and a half
who knows
question yes are you planning on asking
or requiring DHHS to come to defend all
these things we are not liking they were
aware uh today they chose to go to other
committees I believe I told my committee
research I don't researcher I don't know
if that's their best idea because what
will happen is we will start creating
ideas on our own and uh and they may not
they may not like that so so um anyways
I have spoken a lot here but I kind of
brain dumped the process and some ideas
I've had I'd love to hear from others
follow up if I may are they coming if
not today uh they will be invited to
every
um every work session vote that we have
I have our committee researcher who has
excellent reach out to them they were
aware of today do you also know that
there is a DHHS oversight committee and
you know the chairman who can if
necessary subpoena them to come yeah but
uh you know you may uh may may uh may be
worthwhile thank you um so it's it's uh
obviously it was disappointed they
weren't here they were trying to kind of
assess out what was happening
um but you know I don't blame
a lot of this process is just stuff that
the state never went to modernize right
like it's not like they invented this
yesterday right but it's like what's
stopping them from doing it if if they
need a wet signature and the law is
preventing them from taking a digital
signature
we could probably fix that
so yes representative Nelson that's not
regarding the application process but I
wanted to ask you
um the 700 000 fine is that and how is
that assessed is that because uh one or
five or ten or is it per violation how
is that assessed so my let me put the
asterisk of my understanding right
um and I reserve the right to be wrong
about this
um is that it's basically because we
wouldn't be complying with the federal
law
um so it's basically the Maya culpa we
pay to not apply which
speaking personally here I I find kind
of ridiculous it's like so before on
December 6th it was safe and then on
December 7th it wasn't safe
um you know no one here I imagine would
be advocating for not doing a background
check on child care workers anyway am I
hold that position I don't think so
um
if they're not alone with children and
they're in the process of getting a
background check
right
and we were doing it and there wasn't an
incident
and we're having a problem hiring people
what's the issue
so I guess my question is um would it
potentially be more than seven hundred
thousand dollars that we would be fined
if we continued to do it my
understanding is no my understanding is
we pay seven hundred thousand dollars
you want to get on the microphone we'll
just bringing people up we're having
this this is we're not taking any votes
today so this is super informal so feel
free to jump in talk over me we're gonna
we're gonna do something that they
good morning how do you do I'm I'm
Jackie Cowell I am the executive
director of early learning New Hampshire
we are a Statewide non-profit
um and our members are child care
providers and we also advocate for the
families they serve
um with me uh is Marianne barter
um Marianne is the executive director of
Merrimack Valley daycare services we're
serving Concord Pittsfield a few other
towns and also as the chair of the
legislatively enacted New Hampshire
Child Care advisory Council so my
understanding of the seven hundred
thousand dollars and we've been
advocating very much a lot of what
you've just been saying
um our understanding is the seven
hundred thousand dollars is going to
finally potentially be levied against
New Hampshire because New Hampshire like
every other state and I'm trying to
honestly remember what year it started
where the federal government gave States
time to have efficient background check
processes in place and we're allowing
them to do it differently until
recently where they said okay you've had
enough years
you've been wavering this for years and
they've said it to every many states and
New Hampshire has not come up with an
efficient system
um that allows quit turnaround and so
we've heard that it will not be more
than seven hundred thousand dollars
it is also highly likely that New
Hampshire actually won't be charged it's
a threat that many states get uh Vermont
got the same similar kind of threat and
they have decided to keep their waivers
because they did not want to have happen
what you said uh representative Berry
which is
um you're going to lose you're going to
lose the higher
so yeah so I will say from personal
experience
um my chocolate certain episode you know
so maybe maybe you cover me
um the um we just hired a new teacher uh
from New York uh she worked in two New
York Elementary Schools before moving to
Manchester New Hampshire where I also
live
um she's going to leave us in September
to go work in elementary school we'd
love to have her for the summer
specifically because she has a degree in
special education which we have some
children in my Center who would love to
get her hands on we cannot hire her uh
we cannot get her here
um we we want to hire her we had to send
her off to the finger protect process
and I want to get her in I want to get
her to working with my children some of
which you have special needs I can't
I can't I can't get her
um so it's it's a pro I know it's not
such a problem for me but it's an
example of this is somebody who is
actually working in another state
in an elementary school a state that is
by the way more regulated than we are
um and I cannot hire her I cannot start
her at least
um so it's a real problem
um thank you for the at least I'm not
crazy about my 700 000 there I know like
people like I say these things and
people think I'm I'm off my rocker we've
never spoken before by the way so that
wasn't planted Mr Page representative
page excuse me thanks Mr chair
um I can I can get on board with the
idea of a waiver I think my only concern
is
that we not do that without beginning to
address the underlying problem so I
think you know um
we want a practical short-term solution
but I don't want to keep band-aiding it
year after year after year what I'm
hearing here is that we've known that we
didn't have a good system in place for
many years so while I can support the
idea of a short-term waiver I'd like to
make sure as we do that we're also
figuring out what we need to change to
is it
the seven hundred thousand dollars is it
if the state is found to have one child
care center or multiple Child Care
Centers my guess is one I'm saying it's
the process if we continue the process
so if we do one or we do all 589 still
the same it's still the same
um to representative Pages Point
um you know so I I I agree with you
wholeheartedly right like we don't want
to every year have to pay seven hundred
thousand dollars to keep doing to fix
the process right
um so that's why I brought up part of
the fingerprinting process
um there's no reason we have to have
that bottleneck it is purely convenience
um there are people there are people on
the other side of the walls like to say
that want to just go and spend more
money and open up more more
fingerprinting centers
thirty four dollars gets you a
fingerprint pad and the cards
um that anyone can use
um an idea that I've had is our
licensers who go from
Center to Center could carry these
fingerprint pads and do it
um that's an option
um the other option would be another
option I kicked around in my head would
be making while they're while the
department or whoever determines that
there is a shortage of workers would
prioritize these applications
um because it's the state background
check process the two two prong
background check process a federal one
and a state one
um there's no reason to create that
bottleneck or at least we could
prioritize them if we all agree this is
an issue right there's no reason that we
couldn't put them at the top at the
front of the line while there's a
backlog for that right so we there's
legislative ways to kind of like put
them to the front of the line we'd
obviously want to make sure we were
balancing that with the other things
that they're doing because I know like
some medical centers right require this
background check
um so obviously we don't want to not
have nurses
um but it's that's that's something that
that I've that I've looked at but
another one would be just you know if
there's a backlog you got to take the
fingerprint card and that's it and it'll
inconvenience some state workers and
that's fine but
they can take it the FBI took I think I
did 50 plus that the FBI took to give
people Federal security clearance so
it's not like uh it's not like it's
it's not like they can't do it they just
don't want to
thank you um I'm sorry if I missed this
but did you say that basically anyone
can have these fingerprint pads and be
approved to
there is no license requirement in the
state of New Hampshire to take
fingerprints so anyone can do it is it
34 on Amazon
thank you Mr chair
how long does it take for Corey to come
back
uh criminal records release that I do
not have the answer to that question um
I'm sorry hi I'm Marian barter from the
child care advisory Council so the
Department of Safety
efficient and they will get us results
back within 24 to 36 hours The Log Jam
actually exists at unfortunately at DHHS
because they are understaffed so the way
our system works we get our fingerprints
done by the department of safety and
then instead of that information going
straight to the employer it goes through
child care licensing most Industries it
would go straight to the employer so
usually in the medical field or whatever
you get your fingerprints done and then
the hospital will find out whether
you've asked but in our system it has to
bureaucracy I'm sorry I was trying to
think about different word but okay
do you know if that's legislative or is
that or is that a gel thank you you're
representative Williams you just just
run with it you're nailing it
so when you talk just make sure your
why we use that
I we often use an example Rhode Island
which has taken the the
um decision of whether to hire someone
because really what it does is it allows
child care licensing to determine who
we're going to hire which helps us from
a liability standpoint it gives us extra
support but the flip side of that is it
takes much longer and if you if the
burden is on the business person to
decide who they're going to employ and
who they're not going to employ once
that person's found to be employable by
the department of safety it's just a
much faster process
follow us thank you so can I ask you
another question please thank you
um
in the case of the fingerprint
can you run me through that process a
person puts their fingerprints on the
card from that point on what happens
I'm not I it's a very confusing process
and I and I hate to come out as an
expert on this but you would first you
would make your appointment you would go
to the Department of Safety you get your
fingerprints done they would say mail
that information to they would do their
background check and mail the
information to child care licensing
after on my end after I'd had my
fingerprints done I would go back to my
office fill out the required paperwork
um that was mentioned sign it have it
notarized and then sent child care
licensing child care licensing would use
that as the prompt to look to see if
that person's been cleared to work in
the field and unfortunately you are
correct about out of state employees
because we are at the the mercy of other
states to tell us if a person is on is
employable and if they don't after 45
days they're deemed employable so that's
the unfortunate thing about hiring out
of state employees yeah
so I guess I didn't make my question
clear and I apologize for that so I put
my fingerprints on a card I handed in
what happens to that card from that
moment on is it scanned into a computer
and sent out yes the FBI database so
from the moment
one more of course yeah just just just
flow with it we're not so for
from the moment that that is scanned
into the system what is the average
return rate it used to be quite lengthy
now they're trying to get us back to us
between 7 to 14 days and it has come
today child care licensing
but I would never receive it I'm sorry
excuse me I I would never receive
anything from the Department of Safety
so their process is quite quick but then
they communicate with the child care
licensing
so let's go back to the Department of
Safety how long does it take the
Department of State to get that
information
[Music]
that's my point thank you yeah if you
don't mind it's 48 hours so 48 so the
department of safety
um once uh it's 48 Hours turn around and
the problem is the results of those
checks don't go back to the employer
they do with with hospitals hospitals
get them but in child care they can't
know it's got to go to licensing correct
so if we circumvent licensing we send it
to licensing okay they can have it if
they want it but we send it to the
employer so they're going to get the
Corey within 24 hours and they're going
to get the fingerprints without within
48 Hours results so within three days
it's the potential is that that child
care center could hire that person
because all the necessary paperwork is
in place that's right they can hire them
under supervision still so yes and
that's not a waiver situation that saves
that it puts the burden of the
employability on the provider themselves
which I feel comfortable doing that I
feel like I can decide who I want to
hire and who I don't it does take DHHS
out of the decision making about whether
to employ someone and so that has been a
barrier that I think other states have
struggled with and that would be a that
would be a shift in New Hampshire that
DHHS is not determining who we can hire
well a a middle ground of that
um I mean I like the employer making
decisions
um a middle ground to that would be
if they've gotten the fingerprints
the
um
Corey has um was a new acronym uh the
Quarry has sent it to DHHS and the
employer the employer looks at and says
there's nothing in your background check
here that's a problem there's really
nothing in here I'm going to start
you're gonna start working with you you
can't be left alone with children until
you get your stamp from DHHS but you can
at least start
and that saves us seven hundred thousand
dollars and would include and speed up
our background check process
it would
really quickly um so it's the FBI
background check results that come in 48
hours from Department through Department
of Safety there are other background
checks there are other state Registries
that folks that licensing and others are
doing so there's more coming in terms of
findings but it's the FBI national
results that come in 48 hours and that's
where the employer can decide okay no
results I'm going to hire you or not if
you're right and the the federal statute
around the 700 000 that only pertains to
the National background check right
correct so there'd be no there'd be no
fine so there's no fine and we get the
employer employee potentially spun up in
just later though because I actually
believe the 700 000 would be annual so
it would give us a year to it would give
us a year it would buy us time and that
is what the child care advisory Council
and early learning New Hampshire
recommended to our DHHS Partners sure
and just quickly if you don't mind um so
uh Deputy Commissioner assistant
commissioner Eddie Edwards from
Department of Safety they've really
looked into this there is a jet there is
a rule and there is a law which states
in New Hampshire how we have to do it so
those would have to change but it would
still meet federal guidelines so we need
to change the nice part about changing
the laws that just immediately overrides
the rule so
rules are not laws rules are not laws
rules are rules laws are laws
um
okay well hey look at that we actually
uh
we actually have a does anybody have an
idea like kind of preliminary we're
obviously not taking both today so when
I'm legislation in front of us does
anybody have any kind of preliminary
thoughts about this but personally I
think it sounds great
um representative mclames
do we have anyone in the Senate that we
could work with to do an emergency Bill
to address this immediately uh I'm I'm
more than happy to reach out to our
colleagues in the Senate um
very timely and it's something that we
as a committee that's just chomping at
the bit to try to solve problems could
pretty easily solve if we've got a sunny
colleague that we can do a quick bill to
get this in I'm I'm more than happy to
take a punch at that and if you if you
want to be on there with me
um I'm more than happy to be happy
all right I would I would love to do
that and then they'll they'll know that
we are for real so we can also go to the
speaker's office
in um
ask him to uh late drafting late draft
for late drafting yeah if everybody if
everybody here on the on you know the
two teams that exist both teams are
saying do it do it do it I don't see why
we'd have a problem
uh running that through rules the seven
hundred thousand dollars may get people
heartburn but I think they can deal with
it it's all it's all sounding promising
to me I think I just want to hear the
DHHS perspective before
I would sign on to something just so I
can hear why they are advocating
something different send to them because
it's inconvenient yeah it's inconvenient
I hear that and if that's the only
DHHS and at the same time send to the
facility so it's just a BCC or a cc to a
communication like you know it's 2023
you can handle it yeah it would be the
the CC with the caveat that the worker
could start working provided there's
nothing in the background check right if
obviously if there's something that
comes back in there you know
that the employer would then see right
then I guess there's a certain amount of
employer discretion
um but you know if somebody has a you
know DUI from 10 years ago that's not
that doesn't mean you can't work with
children obviously if they were just
arrested for child neglect yeah I had
somebody apply to my child care center
that told me they had been a convicted
of child neglect I said no absolutely
not absolutely Mr chairman one of the
things I find incentivizes people who
don't show up to testify is to let them
know that in two weeks we're going ahead
on this and would love to hear from them
and please come yeah because we're going
ahead otherwise I I have no problem
moving ahead without them in terms of
not voting in my committees we nod which
is a non-vote vote yeah and I think
we're not being so is everybody nodding
um okay nodding nodding not nodding off
but nodding
um I it had it's it from an employer
stand point of view putting my employer
hat on um it is a critical critical
problem because you are commitment yes I
representative on you can I just ask a
quick question and I apologize if we
already covered this but
um aside from your great succession or
suggestion that a simple CC
um should hopefully alleviate some of
concerns trying to get ahead of what
DHHS might not like about what we're
proposing since they were suggesting a
different alternative
um can we identify some of the other
barriers for them um that we can tackle
ahead of time I mean not not speaking
for them my guess is that they're going
to be concerned that they're not giving
the final sign off on somebody to work
there and also maybe from the other
things that they're looking at
um they may say that they want to wait
for those to come back that'd be my
guess I won't say about them
um my Counterpoint to that preemptively
well you were issuing the waivers
beforehand so what became more dangerous
like what my question is on December 7th
what happened what was magical about
December 7th
um other than the other than it's and
then it's nine days before my birthday
I'd like to give you a little background
of something that in December when this
waiver when we first found out the
waiver was going to be eliminated the
Child Care Advocates and providers I'll
talk with the Department talked with the
governor's office talked with the
Department of Safety and it had been the
recommendation of Marianne and I and our
constituents to do exactly this let's
change the law let's just have DHHS I
mean Department of Safety do the back do
the FBI check let's get the results have
a go to the employer that was the
suggestion and just for you to know the
governor's office who does want an
efficient system he wants it to be
corrected in system did say well let
because DHHS had said let's give us a
give us a chance to have it be faster
and that's how it was left
and so far mixed yes open hope in one
hand with DHHS 200 people under what
they can have I would think they would
not mind giving some of their work over
to another department yes and I think
Marianne you might have said it but um
Rhode Island does it in three days
the whole thing and they don't use their
DHHS I uh
I hate getting beat by Rhode Island in
anything
if it was a game of tic-tac-toe versus
Governors I'd be screaming for governor
if I'm understanding correctly ultimate
ultimoyer and JHS is also getting the
information ultimately they still have
you know their control or discretion
um to Nick somebody who is now working
so if I'm following this correctly so in
other words the person is able to start
working sooner and if something
problematic shows up the DHHS has an
issue with it okay so maybe it's been a
week or two weeks that that person's
been in there but um but never being
left alone with children that would be
the caveat never being left alone
children which by the way that was the
waiver you could never be left alone I
had a waiver by the way just FYI
um
upon
the final
completion of the background check yeah
the completion of a background check no
you could hire them with the background
check that you received conditionally
upon
um
backup from DHHS yeah yeah and that
gives you 90 days some in some cases so
now you have an employee who you feel
will be great a great fit for 90 days
and it gives DHHS the opportunity
unfortunately to be at a snail's pace
yeah and hopefully they will hopefully
they'll move expeditiously but at least
at least it will relieve some of the
problems of hiring and getting people
because from what I I know from my own
Center and I know from talking to other
child care centers it's like I have
capacity my Center's capacity up to 60.
I can only take 44 right now because of
teachers not because of space
um if I had space trust me I'd be at 60
like that
um so all right well it sounds like we
have an idea I will work uh with
representative McWilliams uh I will go
over to the speaker's office after we're
done here uh and ask what the process is
for that if they tell me no we'll start
bothering senators and I think we
probably both know Senators who would be
all in to do this sort of deal
um
look at that do we have any other
questions comments concerns about the
all right so that was uh that was
actually refreshing
um now we'll get into this to the uh the
slog of it of
um how do we find ways to get more child
care centers including
um
uh at home centers five plus and that
bill that I think is coming over for the
Senate the 12 the one the basically the
hybrid right the 12 person one am I just
like making that up in my head you know
what I'm talking about what
yes
um so I want to take a look at
um just so we're kind of familiar with
it we're not going to go like all into
this I would highly suggest to the
fellow committee members who start
taking a look at some of the regulations
uh I was doing it last night after
writing an amendment for municipal and
County government which I'm sure they're
going to itl anyways
um but uh I got too tired we fell asleep
um so I'm what I would before we start
this off one fast one pieces of homework
is you know go home and find something
in here that needs to change I certainly
have my ideas they will not be
universally loved
um but
um
oh this is RSA 170 and everything that
touches RSA 170.
um so RSA 170 is just
RSA 170 is not bad I think it's only 35
pages
so this is
they asked me why I wanted to print it
out and I said well because you got to
see it so this is this is double-sided
RSA 170. so RSA 170 is the governing the
principal statutes governing licensed
Child Care Centers obviously they
reference other things about child
safety child neglect child abuse
parental rights
um
he's that might you know focus on focus
on 170 um there's 101 pages of
regulations and four zero zero two
um that we need to kind of start parsing
through a a big thing for me on a
personal level is finding ways to
expedite the application and approval
process
so
um speaking from personal experience
um Let me let me kind of talk about my
child care center and the struggles that
me and my wife went through to
I don't say start our truck we didn't
start when we bought one
so my wife has worked in child care for
17 years
um I have not but she was very
supportive of me in my early career
Pursuits and I wanted to get back to her
so she said I want about chocolate
Center said you know what let's do it so
we found a child care center that had
been pre-ravaged by coven when we go in
the details of that but basically when
everybody went home they didn't need
child care so what happened right
um so we buy this existing Center so
very important existing center right
it's an existing Center
um it's a pretty re-licensed space right
re-licensed existing Center we buy it on
February 28th is when we formally took
possession which was a brilliant move by
the previous owner to make me pay rent
on March 1st did not see that one coming
um it's real fun
um
and then we went through that we we
notify DHHS there but we don't notify
change of ownership because the license
is not to the owner the license is to
the LLC the facility we said notify them
change of director right
because every licensed soccer center has
to have a director
so they
um they say oh well you have to do a
and um in my brain I'm like
no right
um You Don't license the owner you
license the center the center must be in
compliant
um so we go we're not going to find it
right whatever so we go through the
process of basically starting all over
again right my wife was a site director
at a previous spot which the the
differences between a site director and
a director are minute she's easily
qualified she was qualified for a site
director the the changes I think I think
literally the only changes you have to
have some sort of background as a
director in management I think it's very
tiny it's
laughable by the way it's another
regulation we should look at
um so we get the um
we get there we go through the whole
process and then they come out and
inspect the facility
and then another licensor takes over and
it's like well why are you doing this
you already have a license so we go
through this whole rigm roll right of
the inspection they're measuring Drop
Zones right all the stuff that they've
already done to a licensed facility
um and then they were like No And they
actually had to send it up to Legal
because they couldn't comprehend that an
LLC had bought an LLC they like couldn't
comprehend that
um so
that's fine all right so we get a
license we're happy we're operating or
whatever right
um we grow it's great we want to expand
so we're on a strip mall so we just
leased the units that was next to us
which had been vacant for four years
used to be a dentist office which by the
way was great because there was water
that's right there was water in the
rooms like what that was awesome
for my classrooms I could have an
infinite toddler room which I couldn't
have before you you know
um
so we go do it we get the we install the
changing tables with the water right
very easy and we can't get them to come
out and inspect it for the life of us we
can't and we've we've we're already
leasing it right so we're incurring the
cost
um and we're sending emails and we're
calling by the way if any of you picked
up the phone right now and you called
the child care licensing unit no one
would pick up I promise you no one would
pick up I actually thought about doing a
display of like dialing them up and be
like they don't call so we start sending
emails and requesting the general
aligned or a licensor when are you
coming when are you coming when are you
coming
one of them was a straight up ultimatum
we're opening in three days
you can come you cannot we're opening in
three days because we've already taken
people's deposits they're already coming
um still no response and I finally had
to call our executive counselor
and be like why can't I get my facility
licensed and then all of a sudden we got
an inspection
um
it shouldn't be like that
that's problematic for the department
but it's also a statement about like
process right so clearly the department
doesn't understand their process and
felt to me like they didn't understand
urgency right somebody's trying to
expand infant and toddler care in the
state and you're not responsive you're
not scheduling it and you're not showing
up and you have to basically be
politically threatened go thank you Mr
chairman
um what was the period of time between
um you asking and then finally I want to
say it was three to four weeks
um thank you it was not it was not but
but my issue with all this is we need to
find a way to get this process
streamlined we need to find a way to
make it
um
easier for people to do and I think
another problem is we need to find a way
to get the existing child care workers
to want to open their own Center
um because that was something that I
discovered a lot of these workers the
teachers if you will do not want to run
their own centers they don't want to be
directors and that's a huge problem
um most of these businesses they're all
small businesses except for a noticeable
few most of them over one of them are
run by women right so they are eligible
for loans that I am not eligible for
um
there's a process for this and the
department when you go on there um I
sent you I pass it around
um you get a
four page this is it
this is how to open a licensed Child
Care Center in state of New Hampshire
programs receive local approvals to
operate from the zoning board Health
officer online safe chapter as required
by RSA 170.
RC 170.
um programs and application materials is
what's this
cclu reviews for completeness returns if
not complete any complete applications
to refer to license coordinator
licensing business are conducted timely
to ensure the applications are approved
or denied within 60 days when a
corrective action plan is required for
non-compliance and no visits the
corrective action plan is received and
approved and prior to issuing a
six-month number of new programs worth
three license so basically what they do
is they come out they inspect you first
time up you get a six-month license they
come back in six months they make sure
you're doing your job oh I actually have
a problem with that I'm not a licensed
guy but I don't have a problem with that
but I think we can find ways to make
this process I guess demystify it a
little bit I'd like to reduce some
regulations in the in the process but I
like the committee to not necessarily
today because it's a lot but to start
finding ways that we can demystify this
make it easier
um this is basically supply and demand
right if there's more child careers and
whatever like this doesn't benefit me
financially it's sexually horrible for
me to have like competition but if we're
going to let the market work we have to
try to remove the impediments and we
have to try to find a way to demystify
this process to people who have the
passion for it and get them to do the
business side of it and there's some of
that in the RSA to be a director one of
the things you have to do is you have to
have a business management class or a
certain number of hours of supervision
they don't really that doesn't really
make sense that's like those are not
equivalent
um I don't think you really need a
business class to know how to run child
care center it's actually
pretty pretty easy I shouldn't say that
out loud but it's actually pretty easy
it's it's payroll rent
any other things in my experience not
everyone with a vision knows how to do
what you just said yeah yeah and that's
and that's part of the problem so like
how do we get people into that right so
that we can expand this industry get
more child care available fill up some
of these Child Care deserts that we have
which I'm still trying to get the map
from them by the way so if anybody has
that map and the last map I saw was
2019.
um
how we got us as a committee start
thinking about how do we make that
happen
um yes
this isn't necessarily something that I
think we think I don't know that this is
a
answer but um it sort of relates to a
phone call I had last week from um John
Nyan who is the president of the Hampton
Chamber of Commerce and he's also I've
got his exact title but I want to say he
might be uh chair of the Statewide
Chambers of Commerce and this has sort
of been his pet issue but he's taken on
because obviously Workforce is a huge
problem everywhere but especially on the
Seacoast right now
um and so he's been working hard on on
various programs to basically
um allow High School seniors
um to come out of school already ready
to work in licensed trades and he's been
pretty successful at that and I think
he's really interested in moving that
into the child care space as well but
along those same lines I just wonder if
maybe working with the Chambers of
Commerce to develop programs where if
somebody you know you're I think of the
child care teachers in in my kids
centers right and they're wonderful
people but looking at something like
this I think that they would put it
right back down and say that's
overwhelming I I can't do it but if
there's some sort of program similar to
what like score offers
um or the SBA programs that basically
say we'll hold your hand and walk you
through this combined with maybe us
looking legislatively at how we can
reduce some of the barriers with
regulations maybe that's an option no I
like I I'm totally on board with that
concept
um
just me speaking you know we we offer
the state offers and I've brought this
up before the state offers certain
supplementary trainings for child care
workers through they call Pro Solutions
it's the company that administers it
those things are a lot of them are some
of some of them are voluntary not all of
them are mandatory there's no reason we
couldn't develop something for these
teachers because they're supposed to be
doing a certain amount of continuing
education there's no reason we couldn't
I don't I don't want to mandate anything
you know I'm not a mandate guy but
there's no reason we couldn't offer that
as part of this Suite of services that
we're already offering of like hey like
here's how you start a Child Care Center
or here's how you you know manage
basically kind of demystify the process
I love the idea of
basically getting them high school
getting them ready to go in because a
lot of the like my teachers are all very
young they wanted to do that from day
one right like
pop them right on in
um you know and they're very passionate
about it they love it
um I I would love to explore ways to
make that happen
um I would love to do that and I love
the idea of finding a way to get it like
high school credit or something like
that
um
if that's your chosen career field like
go there
to that um he did offer and actually
would love to come up and speak to us at
some point please invite him please
please do I would I would love to get
them up here and talk about that and
find a way to do this because that's a
long-term solution I'm sorry I missed
you I don't know how long anyways
um I think that's a great idea we've had
programs like that in my neck of the
woods that we have then pulled back on I
think the only caution I can put out
there on that is unless we also solve
the S the career sustainability part of
it that we talked about in our last
meeting then I think that's
like sort of a lost cause you know it's
great to get someone into a program
where they're moving right out of high
school and something like this but then
if on the other end of that they don't
see how they can build a life for
themselves and their families on the
wage they're making then I think we're
we're wasting our time you know so I
think we have to we don't if we don't
deal with that part of the issue at the
same time I I don't think we're going
anywhere all right let me ask you a
question
um why does your community pull back
well I would want to invite the director
of the program there to to speak to that
we are having we're having a lot of
issues and we've had a couple different
facility closures in my area I know
there's another facility that's at risk
of closure so do they um do they what is
it what's the issue with just a like in
a brief nutshell do you know or I think
it's
hiring is a huge part of it I know that
one Center has had a hundred percent
turnover it's a I don't know they
probably they've got maybe three
classrooms they've had 100 turnover and
their teachers maybe more than once in
the last couple years
um they're just not able to
pay people to stay yeah okay
um yes
there is actually an official answer to
that which is that in 2015 the
to Early Childhood tracks and those
children were
um diverted into teacher preparation for
public schools so in 2015 we within a
six-month period we lost our pathway
into the field so so one existed and we
just shut it down a truly successful one
existed I mean I I have 50 staff members
30 of those staff came straight out of
those programs and systematically just
ended in 2015. do you have any documents
from that program can you send that to
us that would be I think that would be
wonderful is my only objection to that
[Music]
um
yes
quickly back to your
um discussion about the uh office
of professional licensure I had the
occasion to try to contact them
concerning
a small business in my area
I called and they said uh you know press
one
to get a directory enter the first and
sorry it took me a second to click that
to click in my brain of course I'm like
uh so I knew the first name of somebody
so I kept calling I kept calling four
days
35 phone calls
I finally got a person
and I said I need to get in touch with
somebody in this department can you give
me their first and last name and she
said and I quote
how do I get her extension oh I can't
give that to you oh lovely
well how do I speak with the person oh
my constituent already wrote a letter
and got no response oh well they
so I did find out that they are having a
meeting uh next week and I will be there
and I got an email from a person who I
got her first let last name from the
email
stating we need to know why you're
coming before us
lovely said a constituent complaint
that wasn't enough I got three emails
from three different people
more names so that's a big problem for
people who are trying to open a child
care center to find out what and who
where and when we need to work on that
as well
House Bill 655 in Eda is redoing oplc
this may not be a bad time for a lot
more input than some of this have
if you don't mind of course um so uh the
ctes actually did end because the career
was not considered one that could make
ends meet and so that was one of the
reasons the high schools did discontinue
it and I have a question if you don't
mind um did you say John Lyons
oh thank you
so that's you know and to kind of Bring
It Back full circle because we are oh
I'm sorry I am a little confused about
that because I have personal experience
my daughter actually went through a CTE
program at Pinkerton Academy where she
obtained her LNA and so that
um obviously the hourly wage of an LNA
would be similar to the
wage of somebody who would be a child
care worker so how could they have
Justified that like what did I don't
know that was again in 2015 that that
was what was happening they all stopped
I'm sorry
um it was justified it was really
a decision that was made on a very low
level that got past the commissioner
because when the child care advisory
Council went back and said this is an
enormous mistake and should not be
happening they were able to reverse
their decision making but by then all of
the lab schools had closed so there was
no point it was very very frustrating so
I believe the last CTE program live
um lab school has closed recently it's
just been and I I think to bring It full
circle and what we ended is because
we're at the end of the hour
um
to bring this full circle
they need to see that running their own
Center is a logical career I don't want
to say endpoint but let's say
viable oh trust me it's very viable uh
it's very viable
um
we need to kind of open that path up and
some of that's going to be a cultural
issue honestly of getting people to
understand it's it's scary to have
employees but yes you can pay them and
their money will be there and you'll be
fine
um so
um with that I think um does anybody
have anything else because I wanted to
be about an hour today and uh roll out
yep Nelson I'm I'm really bad at taking
minutes so I'm really nervous about this
whole thing I didn't I'm sorry I did not
get your last name and I did not get
where you're from I really apologize no
because that's fine it's Marianne
m-a-r-i-a-n-n-e barter
b-a-r-t-e-r okay and I'm the executive
director at Merrimack Valley daycare
service but I'm the chair of the New
Hampshire Child Care advisory Council
you know a little bit about Child Care
thank you okay so we're gonna end this
up with this got some marching orders
here uh I'm gonna go to the speaker's
office right now uh and see if we can
late file uh a bill I'm the first thing
that's fine can we do it right if we
can't do it uh we'll start I'll let you
know representative we'll start um
bothering some Senators to get a late
draft
um I will look into where we said it was
a license we said it was a law and a
rule
right so I don't really care about the
rule too much because we'll override
that with the law
um but I'll start looking into that
where it's appropriate
um and we have let's say a nod agreement
on
um on the background check process
itself
um drafting piece of legislation that
will allow the query to send the results
to the employer and DHHS simultaneously
the employer will then have discretion
based on the returns to allow the child
care worker to work in a supervised
capacity
um 90 days let me write that down
because I will forget that thank you
um while DHHS makes its final assessment
and then we will uh I will go in and ask
for seven hundred thousand dollars
and be super super loved uh for that
casual just it was a just a little
walking around money a little phone to
build up money
um and um figure out what the appetite
is there for that part on the personal
level I don't have a problem with it uh
if it kills us on late drafting
but we'll find out we have some
political questions we have to answer
I'm sorry a lot of questions I have
um but but what you were saying before
is it's not certain that we would even
be fined the seven hundred thousand
dollars that we may be fined according
to what you were talking about sure okay
that was also my understanding this FYI
is that we may I I I hold I I would love
our Congressman to explain why we're
paying a 700 000 fine uh to hire child
care workers
um if they want to get in front of us
and tell us that they're more than
welcome to anyways I will go and uh I do
have to ask right because it could
happen right um figure out what the
appetite is there for that
um the co-work sound for the Committees
we're gonna start looking at these
regulations and rules
um and uh find some ways to make things
a little better and we're going to find
a way to kind of expedite these uh
getting these new child care centers
spun up so it's not a uh send it off two
months later they might inspect you
um so we're gonna take a look at that
does anybody else have any questions
comments or concerns before I close this
up and go for an early learning you guys
know how I love lunch all right thank
you oh yes representative Williams I'm
just
I'm just a whole bunch of child care uh
Center employers come and testify in
front of us for about two months and we
compiled a finding list so it's probably
similar to some of the things you're
experiencing but a much broader depth of
potential Solutions so I think it's
timely and it may give us a little bit
of cliff notes for when we're reviewing
this 35 page total and thank you for
doing yeah thank you for doing that the
next time we meet I don't know if we'll
meet in two weeks or three weeks uh once
again we don't have legislation although
if we get that emergency thing drafted
I'm going to demand that comes to us so
we may have legislation
um but
um I will I will literally lose my mind
if it doesn't come to us probably
um so um I'll let I gave the community I
think you guys had two weeks notice this
time I'm gonna try to keep doing that I
know we don't meet regularly and I know
we have two two or three members who
have other things at the same time so
trying to box it off really early but
with that
um I'm gonna end this work session thank
you guys so much I'm glad we actually
got something sort of kind of done and
foreign